buckle up mr. Burton breaking news we're
getting here from Iran TV that there's
been a stampede at the burial procession
for general Qasem Soleimani you remember
he's being buried in his hometown of
Kara man after being killed in a u.s.
airstrike on Friday so Iran TVs
reporting there's been a stampede at the
burial procession for Qasem Soleimani in
his hometown of Quetta man no reports
yet on fatalities if there are any but
we are getting reports that there could
be some people who are injured let's go
to our correspondent in the Iranian
capital Tehran I said babe I said so
we're hearing now that there's been a
stampede at the funeral not surprising
given the numbers of people have turned
out there what more have you been
hearing there in the capital
well we're hearing that there have been
some casualties there was a stampede we
understand it's not yet clear how many
people have been injured or hurt but as
you can see from the pictures there are
hundreds and thousands of people out on
the streets that scene has been
replicated across the country but in
Carmen it's a city and that number of
people in those narrow streets all
moving in the same direction as the
coffin passes through it's it's not
surprising that this has happened but
we're still waiting for information in
terms of how many people have actually
been hurt and we've seen these pictures
on our TV screens a set of just hundreds
of thousands of people have turned out
for this burial procession today but of
course this has been going on now for a
number of days that certainly the last
three days in terms of the funeral
processions making their way to the holy
cities and also to the Capitol yeah this
is a third and final day of mourning the
the body of Qasem Soleimani is said to
be buried at a cemetery that was his
wish to be buried alongside those that
were killed during the iran-iraq war but
this final day I think that many people
that haven't been able to attend the
other gatherings in Mashhad in Tehran
and come have made their way to this
final burial so this could mean that
people from outside of the city of
Garman are attending so it's increased
those numbers but this is a specific
event it's not like the funeral prayer
yesterday in Tehran which the open space
and even here in Tehran yesterday was
very busy and his body will be taken to
a graveyard so it opens up it kind of
makes it very difficult when people are
traveling in these narrow spaces going
in one direction to that specific
graveyard and that could be one of the
reasons why this stampede has happened I
suggest just a final thought to you I
mean we haven't heard much about care
man other than the fact that of course
it is Qasem Soleimani z-- hometown just
described for us this city isn't a big
city small city what is it
it's not a very big city but what's
happened here is that because he is such
a national hero because many people see
him as a patriot and his assassination
has essentially created unity for the
government many different political
factions now are all in agreement that
they are condemning his assassination
but also many people looked up to Qasem
Soleimani so they will have converged on
this small city and maybe the
infrastructure and the streets and the
city is not really built for dealing
with this many people on this one
specific occasion remember people have
not seen this number of people out on
the streets for 30 years since the
funeral of the founder of the Islamic
Republic Ayatollah Khomeini so this
funeral has been passing through
different cities and this is its final
day of mourning it's on it's the body's
on its way I understand to the cemetery
but I think that the number of people
the vast number of people the hundreds
of thousands on the street and this
small city can lend itself for something
like this happening yeah so let's just
remind our viewers here if they're just
joining us on al-jazeera that we
understand there's been a stampede
at this burial procession for Qasem
Soleimani the Iranian general who was
assassinated by a US drone strike on
Friday so the pictures you're seeing
alive from Quetta man which is the
hometown of Qasem Soleimani so you're
watching pictures of the funeral
procession there we understand a
Stampede happened just a short while ago
we understand that there have been some
fatalities we don't know yet how many
and how many have been injured was with
we're talking to our reporter I said beg
who is in the Iranian capital Tehran I
said just talk us through the events
what we know about what's happening now
in Cairo man in terms of this funeral
procession so we've seen some of the
pictures in our screen but just tell us
what's been happening there today
so is the final day of mourning 3 days
of mourning yesterday was a national
holiday but today the body of God some
ceremony is being buried at the cemetery
as per his wishes he wanted to be buried
alongside those that died fighting
during the iran-iraq war so it's not
pertain to for those people that haven't
been able to attend the other funeral
processions taking place across the
country in Mashhad in the holy city of
Rome in Iran the funeral pray in Tehran
yesterday to be able to attend his
burial so people have converged on this
city we've seen posters of Qasem
Soleimani put up across the country on
the side of the roads over highways even
when you go to an ATM machine to take
money out you can see his image on those
screens some of those images show him in
his military fatigues others being
embraced by the supreme leader Ayatollah
Khomeini and also some showing him being
welcomed into heaven so this is a very
popular figure he has United many
different political factions but this is
the final day he's meant to be buried
and people have converged on this city
and we were also hearing chants a
calming character of God man and those
chants are the same that we've been
hearing across the country and that is
intercom that's the Farsi word for
revenge and a lot of people are still
very emotional very angry asking for
revenge all right our reporter Assad
back there in the Iranian capital terror
and acid just updating us there about
the latest developments from Cairo man
which is the hometown of Qasem Soleimani
the senior Iranian general who headed up
the hoods force and the Iranian the
Iranian Revolutionary Guard who was
assassinated in a US air strike last
Friday that has been a stampede at the
funeral these are pictures you're seeing
on your screen
some mourners have been killed we're
still getting details more news of
course at the top of the hour with my
colleague Hallett mccurdy